[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN SULLIVAN: Hi.
Welcome to "Cloud OnAir."
These are live webinars that
Google Cloud is hosting,
and we're doing
them every Tuesday.
My name's Brian Sullivan.
I'm the senior program manager
with Google Earth Outreach.
And I'm here with--
DAVID KROODMSA:
I'm David Kroodsma.
I'm the director of research
at Global Fishing Watch.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about how Google Fishing
Watch uses Google Cloud.
Throughout our
whole presentation,
there'll be Googlers standing
by to answer your questions.
So you can just type
them in on the platform,
and they'll be ready
to answer them.
So let's get started.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: Great.
So within Google, we have
a team called GO for Good,
and our goal is to take on some
of the world's most pressing
issues around the environment,
conservation, public health,
and other humanitarian issues.
And fishing is actually
one that really relates
to a lot of these issues.
So when we think
of fishing, this
is what we
traditionally think of.
It's a quiet morning.
We're out there.
And we're with nature.
But the reality of
industrial fishing
is actually quite different.
It's something
that, as a society,
is very difficult to comprehend.
This is an example of
a moratorium in China,
where for three months,
they closed fishing
so that all the fish could
recuperate and rebound
their stocks.
But at the end of three months,
this is what's coming for you.
And you can count all the
boats that are in here.
And once you get a sense of
how big you think this is,
you can zoom out
a little bit more
and get a better extent of just
what global fishing looks like
and the pressures that puts on
the environment and our food.
You can zoom out one
more time, and you really
start to understand
how big this is.
And we have these photos
because a photojournalist was
out there, and
they set these up.
But how could we zoom out
and see the entire world?
What would that look like
if we could truly understand
the extent of global fishing?
That's what Global Fishing
Watch is enabling us to do.
So we're going to switch
over to our live demo
now to show you something that's
free for the entire world.
And anyone is able to
go online and start
to understand how much we're
actually fishing our oceans.
Now, the first thing you'll
see is all these blue dots
in the middle.
And these are our
fishing algorithms
that are determining where
we're actually seeing fishing.
And this is an interactive
map, so I can pan around.
And I can zoom into
different areas.
And one of the
things that we'll see
is that there are some spots
in the middle of the Pacific
that are wide open, and
we see lots of fishing.
And then we see
other holes in these
where we have things like
marine-protected areas
or country boundaries that
are dictating whether or not
people are allowed to
fish in these regions.
And you'll see very
different patterns
right along the
country's borders
versus out in
international waters where
people are deciding who has
the right to fish there.
Now, the same way we
can see this macro view
and zoom all around on
this, we can actually go in
and see an individual vessel.
And so what we'll be doing
now is you'll see a pink line,
and that is going to be--
an individual vessel, the
[? Val ?] [? Matalle. ?] No.
Ah, the joys of live demos.
And so as we play
this forward, you'll
be able to see an
individual vessel.
And so out of this
pink line in here,
we can see how that's changing.
So go into our Layers, and
we'll go on to our Activity.
And let's turn off all the
other background behind that.
And now, you can see
the distinct pattern
that a boat makes when it
fishes, when it's wiggling back
and forth like that versus
when it's transiting,
and it has the straight
lines in between.
Looking at one more
example, you can
see where MPAs and other areas
like that have been created.
[INAUDIBLE]
Sorry.
That was the problem, when
you switch resolutions.
All right, well, thanks for
bearing with us on that.
But the question is, why
does a company like Google
look at something like fishing?
And so over a billion
people in the world
depend on fish as their
primary source of protein.
About 90% of the apex,
or the largest species,
have disappeared
within our lifetime.
85% of the world's fisheries are
either overfished, at capacity,
or are recovering.
About one in five, or
20%, of the world's fish
are considered IEU--
Illegal, Unregulated,
and Undocumented.
And then when we look at
this at a global level,
this is about a $60 billion
market that is really affecting
developing countries the most.
And that ties down to
food security, [INAUDIBLE]
down to sovereign rights,
and a lot of other issues,
like slave labor, that you
wouldn't think of initially.
So let's talk a little bit
about how this is actually
working behind the scenes.
DAVID KROODMSA: Great.
Thank you, Brian.
So I'm David Kroodsma.
I run the research program
at Global Fishing Watch.
And Global Fishing Watch
is a small nonprofit
dedicated to
increasing transparency
in the global fishing
industry, and a lot of what
we do is using Google tools.
And I'm going to go into details
of how that technology works,
how you make those really nice
maps that Brian just showed us.
The key technology is something
called Automatic Identification
System, or AIS, that all
large, ocean-going vessels have
to carry.
And what it does-- it
has a little GPS in it,
and it broadcasts the
vessels' locations,
so the other boats nearby
can see where it is
and, thus, avoid collisions.
It's a safety device.
These signals, though,
are broadcast to a radio.
And they can be picked up by
satellites flying overhead
or a network of antennas
along the world's coastline.
And what we have done
at Global Fishing Watch
is obtained a global database
of all of these AIS messages
and then processed them.
If you plot all of these
messages on a map, what you see
is, over one year, something
that looks like this.
This is one of my favorite maps.
You can see all the
world's shipping lanes.
You can see where
fishing is happening.
You can see places
near Antarctica
where boats don't go.
This is all vessels.
Only about one out of
five are fishing boats.
So now, we have
this big database,
and we have two
classification problems.
One, we want to identify
which of the vessels
are fishing vessels and what
type of fishing vessels.
And two, for those
vessels, we want
to identify when
they're fishing.
And so this is where we use the
Cloud-- we use Google Cloud.
First, let's start
with the first problem,
identifying what's a fishing
vessel and what type.
So in AIS messages, they
broadcast the name and call
sign of a boat.
And we've been able
to take these messages
and match them up to
official registries
to figure out what type of boat
about slightly more than 50,000
of these almost
300,000 vessels are.
So that tells us, say, whether
it's a tugboat, whether it's
a trawler, and so forth.
So we have this
large training data,
and then we have
to be able to infer
what the other vessels are.
Fortunately, boats have
very different patterns
of how they move in
the ocean, depending
on what type of vessel it is.
So here on the left,
you can see the paths
of a trawler, which is a
fishing vessel that drags
a net behind it to catch fish.
In the middle is the path
of a longline, which,
as its name applies,
is-- sets long lines
of hooks that can be
up to 100-kilometers
long in the ocean.
And then on the right
is a purse seine,
which encircles schools of
tuna or other fish with a net
and draws them in that way.
Each of them has
a distinct pattern
which you can recognize
with your eye, which
means we can probably train
a model to do the same thing
and differentiate them.
But to train that model, first
we have to process this data
and create features for our
machine learning algorithm.
And we do all that
in Google products.
So every day, we get about 50
million unique AIS messages.
And we run those messages.
We paralyze those
messages in Dataflow.
And the first thing we do
is something very simple.
We just create realistic
segments with every--
all the messages from these
vessels and get rid of noise
such that you have paths
that you can work with.
There's actually a lot
of noise in the AIS
that needs to be cleaned up.
And then, we put
that into BigQuery.
BigQuery is Google's platform--
it's an SQL-like
database that allows you
to do terabyte-sized queries.
It returns very
quickly, and it's
very useful for all
of our analyses.
Now, we have all
these points, and we
want to figure out spatial
information about each,
such as the distance
to shore, whether it's
in the exclusive economic
zone of China or Japan,
distance to port.
And we do that by taking
global shape files,
such as the one of all the
world's coastlines or one
of all the world's ports, and
do calculations in Dataflow
to find out for each
position in the world,
that one-kilometer resolution--
so that's about 30 million
points--
the distance to the shore
and distance to port.
We then take those rasters,
upload them to BigQuery.
And then, it's very nice.
We're able to do a
join, because that's
what you can do in BigQuery,
across these millions
and millions of positions to
get that spatial information
about every single position.
So now, we have a nice
useful data set in BigQuery.
And we want to create features
for our machine learning
algorithm.
We have about 30 billion
AIS messages in all.
This on the scale of a terabyte.
And we continue, on Dataflow,
to do some calculations
for each single position,
where you calculate
11 different features.
These are simple things, such
as the time between positions,
the implied speed
between positions
of a vessel, how far
that is from shore,
how far that point is from an
anchorage, the time of day.
And so now, we have
some information
about all these
features and we want
to train a model to
identify what type of boat
it is based on these features.
To do that, we use a common type
of machine learning algorithm
called the convolutional
neural network.
This is a type of--
this algorithm has
actually become very common
in image recognition
and is probably
very similar to what Google
Photos uses to identify what's
a cat and what's not a cat.
And here's how it works.
So we're taking--
for each vessel,
say we have about
13,000 positions
we're going to try to use to
identify what type of boat
it is.
And each of those
positions has 11 features,
so that's over 100,000
features per vessel.
And we run something--
we run a convolution--
a nine-layer
convolution across it,
which essentially reduces
the number of features down
to something more manageable--
in this case, about 2,000--
which we can then run across
a fully-connected network
to get 14 different vessel
class probabilities.
So the output of
this is a number
that tells you whether or
not the neural net thinks
the boat is a
tugboat, whether it
thinks it's a trawler, whether
it thinks it's a longliner.
This next slide
shows how well we
think something called a
confusion matrix, which
is a common tool
used for identifying
how well machine learning
algorithms do at classification
problems.
It's a little
complicated to read.
But basically, one row of
this is all the vessels
from one class in our test data.
And the column is how many
of the boats from that class
the neural net thought
was in that class.
So basically, high numbers
along the diagonal is good.
That means that vessels
from the test data
were labeled with the
same value in the--
by the neural network.
And as you look at
this, it gets almost--
has a very high accuracy
on our data set.
A lot of the vessels it gets
wrong, I've looked at them.
Oftentimes, they're
very inactive vessels
or they're some vessels which
have kind of mixed class
or outside of these 14 classes.
So we do a good job identifying
what's a fishing boat
and what's not and the
type of fishing vessel.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So how many
boats are you looking at here?
DAVID KROODMSA:
We're looking at--
so there's 300,000
vessels in the world.
In one year and
across all years,
it's actually closer to
400,000, because some boats
aren't active every year.
And there's about
60,000 fishing vessels
active in one year and about
70,000 active across all years.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: OK.
So it's about
70,000 vessels that
are being shown in the public--
DAVID KROODMSA: Yes.
BRIAN SULLIVAN:
--Global Fishing Watch.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yes.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: And then
there's the full 300,000
that we're doing our
own analytics on inside.
DAVID KROODMSA: Exactly.
No, that's a good
point, because when
you look at Global
Fishing Watch,
you're just seeing
the fishing vessels.
But in order to
identify them, we
have to process all the vessels.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: OK.
DAVID KROODMSA: So that then
brings us-- so now we know--
oh, the other thing I
think is really exciting
about this is that big
boats move differently
than small boats.
So our model can also tell
how large the vessels are.
This is the length, engine
power, and tonnage of--
on the x-axis here is
from our test data.
And the y-axis is what
the model predicts.
And it does a really good job
of predicting how big boats are,
which can be useful for
all types of studies.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So
what you're doing here
is you're taking the AIS,
which is kind of like a GPS
track of the boat, and the
only information you have
is how fast it's
moving and when we're
seeing a signal from that.
And with that
information, you're
figuring out how big of a boat
it is, how much power it has,
and then just like how
much it's weighing as well?
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
It's kind of-- I think
it's kind of amazing.
But that's exactly
what we're doing.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So
it's like Strava
for all the world's ships.
DAVID KROODMSA:
[LAUGHS] Yeah, exactly.
Essentially.
Yeah, and it can tell what's--
you know, and it's--
it's amazing how much
you can tell just
based on how it moves.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: OK.
DAVID KROODMSA: Which is
the next thing, which is you
want to know when it's fishing.
So now, we know what
type of boat it is.
And you want to look
at how it's moving.
And you want to say,
OK, this is a trawler.
And right now, we think it
has its net in the water.
Or this time-- or you want
to say, this is a trawler.
Right now, it doesn't
have its net the water,
and it's going to port.
Because you want to say
where fishing is happening.
And the way we do
that is we need--
just like with the
vessel classification,
we need label data.
So we need to know
where fishing--
we need to take all the data--
we need to take, basically,
all the tracks of boats
and label each position
as fishing or non-fishing.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: OK.
DAVID KROODMSA: This turned
out to be a lot of work.
[LAUGHS] We had
to manually label
more than a million points.
This is a case where grad
students are your friend.
We partnered with a number
of research institutions
that helped us with this.
And we built up a
JavaScript tool--
you can see a
screenshot of it here--
in something called PYBOSSA.
And you can label-- what we
do is you look at these tracks
of the boat and we were--
fisheries experts
helped train us.
And you label each position
as fishing or non-fishing.
We labeled more than
a million positions.
The way we did this largely
also was me every day
bothering people
on Slack and then
sending out encouraging
notes or critical ones
if they were not
labeling enough.
We did that for two months.
And then, we were able
to train our model.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So at
Google, there's a--
machine learning is something
that's coming up all the time.
And usually whenever
someone wants
to apply machine
learning to a project,
the biggest issue is
getting training data.
And so how long does
it take you to amass
a million points like this?
DAVID KROODMSA: So it was--
we were helped out a lot by--
the grad student had basically
spent a year doing this.
So that was quite helpful.
Thank you, Christina,
if you're listening.
And then, it took two months
to get another few hundred--
basically, she did half of it.
And then, it took us two months
to get another half of that
through me bothering
everyone on Slack
and a team of about 10
people spending each
some time during the day.
So we calculated
that it would take--
if we were to do this
across the whole data set--
it would take us about--
I think it was like 400 years to
label all the fishing activity.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: Oh,
so you're saying
that if a human were to
do it at the same speed
that a grad student would
do it, that grad student
would be worth 400 years.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
And one of the tricky
things here is we
couldn't-- there's a
lot of nice tools--
I know Google's been developing
these to kind of outsource
these labeling projects
for creating label data.
But we actually had to
be trained to do this,
because we needed to
have kind of expert
decisions about what's
fishing versus not.
So we couldn't outsource it in
the way we might have liked to.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So
it's a nice example
for machine learning where like
if a human looks at the track,
they kind of have an intuitive
sense of why it's fishing
or it's not fishing.
But there's not a
clear formula that you
can run the same way on.
DAVID KROODMSA: And there is,
to some extent, by gear type.
But all those rules
are complicated enough
that it's better to have
human judgment put on it.
And so the output of it
is a table like this.
This is a view of
what's in BigQuery.
And the far right
column is the--
NNS, Neural Net Score.
And it's one if we think the
boat is fishing and zero,
or null, if we don't think.
So now, we have every single
one of our data points labeled
as fishing or not fishing.
And we also think we know what
types of vessels they are.
So now what we can do is
a-- now, we can do analyses.
Now, we can tell
stories and make maps.
One thing I do almost every day
is write queries in BigQuery
and then also link up
to that using Python.
This is a screenshot
of an IPython notebook
where I have a query that is
trying to group the group's
data from a BigQuery table
into latitude and longitude
to make a grid.
I use [INAUDIBLE] library.
It has a nice--
it has a module for
connecting up with BigQuery.
I take that out into
a raster, and then I
can map it and do analyses.
And so here is a global map
of just the fishing vessels
while we think they are
fishing in one calendar year.
And this is basically
a scientific product,
the same thing that
Brian showed you earlier
and what we're showing
on that global map.
If I changed the way I write
that query to query only
by specific gear
types, I get a map
of where all trawlers
in the world are.
And you can see they fish
along the world's coastlines.
They often drag their
nets along the sea floor,
so they stay close
to the shore--
drifting longlines, which set
those hooks 100-kilometers long
out in the high seas; purse
seines, which encircle fish
with their nets.
And so you can see
each fishing pattern
has a distinct
location in the world.
So in summary, we are
taking in an AIS feed
from over 30
satellites and hundreds
of terrestrial receivers
with almost 50 million AIS
messages per day from 300,000
vessels across a year over six
years of data.
We then, also, for
the training, we're
using vessel registries to
identify the types of boats
and also the over 20,000
manually-labeled track segments
or a million positions.
We put that all together through
the various Google tools.
And what we get out is about
70,000 fishing vessels,
14 gear types--
14 vessel types
of which half are
fishing types, the
size of vessels,
when we think they're fishing,
and all of these wonderful maps
and data that you see available.
One thing I should add is that
we're trying to make as much
of the data publicly available,
as well as our code base,
so that our machine learning
algorithms, which we also
run through TensorFlow and
Cloud ML, are our open source.
And you can go to
globalfishingwatch.io
and find links to
those GitHub reposts
to see how we actually did this.
And again, it would
take about 400 years
for me bothering you on
Slack to complete it.
We used Google products at
almost every step of the way.
We use Dataflow, which is
really nice for scaling up
Compute Engine
instances, so we don't
have to worry about allocating
all of our resources
or keeping too many
machines running.
BigQuery is how we store a lot
of our data and run queries
on it.
I use it every day.
Cloud ML is-- and TensorFlow
we use for our models, Cloud
Storage as well.
Apps Engine is used on the
map, as well as Maps API,
for showing off the interactive
map that Brian showed you
earlier.
And then, I'll talk
a little bit more
about Earth Engine, which
is another platform used
for analysis.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So
one of the things
about Global Fishing Watch
is it's a partnership now
between Google, that
was a founding partner,
and, initially, two other
non-profits, SkyTruth
and Oceana.
And now, we've stood it up as
its own independent nonprofit.
So it's been a great
opportunity as these projects
were evolving.
When we were in the early
stages of Global Fishing Watch,
Dataflow was just coming out.
So being able to give external
people alpha access to this
to really refine what were
the features that we needed,
what worked well, and what
didn't, has been really fun.
And so I know BigQuery
is one that we
have a whole team
of data scientists
that don't really have
the background in systems
administration
and really scaling
massive parallel computing.
But by being able to
do everything directly
in BigQuery, they were
comfortable in SQL.
And suddenly, they were
doing these massive analyses
that they wouldn't have
been able to do otherwise.
DAVID KROODMSA: And that's
kind of a lot of where I sit,
actually.
Because I'm doing a
lot of the analyses
and working with our engineers
who are doing some of the more
distributive stuff.
And it's actually been kind
of fun over the last few years
to see us kind of move over to
these new platforms which are
auto-scaling and which are
kind of doing the same thing
for BigQuery-- that BigQuery's
done for me for some of these,
like the Cloud ML
and the compute--
and the Dataflow.
Because at the end
of the day, I don't
want to worry about how to scale
up all these compute instances
and all that.
That's why BigQuery is
so nice, because I never
have to think about
the parallelization.
It just does it.
And that bring us
back to the analysis,
because really, what we
care about is getting
useful information out of this.
And so a large part
of my job is working
with 11 different research
institutions in our research
program to take this
massive data set
and turn it into
useful knowledge.
And we're doing that through
over 25 different research
projects.
We have 10 papers
already published;
many, many more in the works.
And I'm gonna give you
two examples of what
we can do with this.
One is just simply
people are trying
to understand how
fishing responds
to different temperatures.
So what you're looking
at here is an animation.
The background shows
sea surface temperature,
and then the dark blue is
drifting longline fishing
activity over the
course of one year.
And you can watch the
fishing activity move,
and you can watch the
temperatures change.
Some of our researchers
are building models
to see how fishing responds
to changing temperatures.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: Just to
make sure we understand--
you're saying that
near the equator,
the water is a lot hotter, and
so you can actually see like
little jet streams and things
like this coming off of-- that
may not be the right
scientific term, but--
DAVID KROODMSA:
Yeah, yeah, it works.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: But you can see
currents coming through here
and how those
temperatures are shifting.
And all the wiggling
dots in the middle
is where they're using longline.
And then down here, this
would be much colder water
near the poles.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
And I'm going to zoom in now to
between Australia and Africa.
The colors will change.
Yellow is very warm, black is
cold, and the white fishing
activity.
And this is between May
and September of 2016.
And you can watch and
see the fishing activity
follow this kind of
constant temperature
as the gradient moves northward.
And it's really
cool, and we've been
able look at how this
changes between years.
And we can now model this.
And this is useful for
all types of things,
ranging from how we
manage the oceans now
and thinking about where
fishing is happening,
how to allocate permits
to thinking about how
to respond to climate change.
And we built this--
this graphic you're
seeing here was
built using Earth
Engine, which is
a Google platform for doing
very large global raster
calculations.
And that's with the sea surface
temperature model built into it
at very high resolution
daily, that we're
able to compare with
our fishing activity.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So we're
seeing as the waters get warmer
and move north,
you're saying the fish
follow that same temperature.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: And
then the fishing boats,
or the predators, are
following them the same way.
And I think there's
actually researchers
that are looking at, like, what
would be the migration paths
for different fish
and other species
like that as we have sea
surface temperatures rising
across the board and then,
how will other ones be
squeezed in and out?
And so this is giving
new tools for them
to look at that,
that weren't really
possible or available before.
DAVID KROODMSA: A second
project that's good to highlight
is something called
transshipment.
So some vessels, instead
of returning to port
and offloading
their fish at port,
they meet up with refrigerated
cargo vessels at sea
to offload their fish.
And they do this partially
because sometimes, it
can save fuel.
But another reason is that
it can also help obscure
where the fish was caught and
what vessel caught the fish.
And this is one way that
illegally-caught fish enters
legitimate markets.
It also allows vessels to stay
at sea for a very long time
without coming into port, which
has been shown to be associated
with instances of
essentially slavery at sea
and also other
illicit activities.
And so our essential goal
is to create transparency.
Not all of this
transshipment is bad.
But where our goal is
to create transparency,
we can understand
where it's happening.
And so we can better
assess its activity.
If you could imagine,
this is basically--
we have all the positions
of all the boats in AIS,
and we want to see
when two boats meet up
at sea, which is basically
a cross-join between tens
of millions of positions, which
is an enormous calculation.
We do this in Dataflow
by gridding the world up
and breaking it down
into smaller pieces,
so we can identify everywhere
one fishing vessel meets up
with a refrigerated cargo
vessel at sea for several hours.
And from that, we're able to
create the first ever global
map of transshipment behavior.
So this shows the--
the red dots here
show everywhere we see a
refrigerated cargo vessel
and a fishing vessel
meet up at sea.
And the light blue
dots are places see--
where we think transshipment
might be occurring,
with less confidence.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: So
what you're saying
is if you look in these
photos, this smaller boat
is the actual fishing vessel.
And then that pulls alongside
the larger refrigerated vessel,
or like a tanker, and then
they offload everything
from the small boat
onto the big boat.
And so the big boat may
not actually be fishing,
but it meets up with all these
small boats around the area
and then brings that back
into a central place.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
And the reason you
want to do this
is because big boats are
more efficient at crossing
the ocean than small boats.
And so you can save
fuel if you do this.
But again, it also
obscures supply chains.
And so Brian's going to
talk a little bit more
about why this matters.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: Yup.
So one of the other impacts that
we've seen of transshipments
is that the same way they'll
be moving fish from a fishing
vessel onto a cargo
vessel, they'll
also bring supplies and all
kinds of other materials
back onto the fishing
vessel, so the fishing
vessel could stay out for
months and months at a time.
And the AP did some incredible
investigative reporting.
And then what they found is
that in a lot these cases,
the crew is actually
related to slave labor,
because they're literally
trapped on the boat
and unable to leave.
And so being able
to help map out
where transshipments
were happening
was a key piece for
helping them to understand
where these vessels
might be going
and how these
supplies are going.
DAVID KROODMSA:
And those pictures
you saw earlier of those
transshipments vessels,
those were actually taken from
satellites working with members
of Global Fishing
Watch who are looking
at AIS data of those large
cargo vessels and saying,
we think there's a boat here.
Why don't you tell your
satellite to take a picture?
So it's-- yeah.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: And
that's moved on to--
I think the next slide is--
here's another example
where in Palau, people
were looking at
poaching that was
happening within a small
country in the Asia-Pacific.
And in many cases, being able
to see this as it was happening,
they were able to send
out enforcement vehicles
from the government to
pull alongside these.
And "The New York
Times Magazine"
did a whole piece
on the story of how
a lot of these
developing countries
are being taken advantage of by
more developed and industrial
fishing countries and
companies to exploit this.
And so adding transparency to
a space that was traditionally
out of sight and out of mind is
really revolutionizing the way
people can more sustainably
manage these areas.
Indonesia is a
country that we've
been working closely with.
The person here in this
picture is Ibu Susi.
She's the minister of
fisheries and foreign affairs.
She reports directly
to President Jokowi.
And shortly after
we first announced
that we're working on
Global Fishing Watch,
she came to Google.
And she met with
us, and she said,
how do I use technology
like this in Indonesia?
And so she's been
extremely progressive.
And she is the
first country ever
to take what was traditionally
very proprietary data--
so she's supplementing
our AIS work
with what we call VMS, or
Vessel Monitoring Systems,
which is proprietary
government data.
And what they found is that
while a lot of these countries
and companies have more
data than they can handle,
the challenge isn't
the lack of data.
The challenge is pulling
out insights from them.
And so by taking her
data and running it
through all of our
machine learning programs,
we've been able to give her
back a lot of the other insights
and let her and her teams
and her navy have more views
into what's actually
happening, so they
can focus on specific
things instead of swimming
in all of that data.
When we talked about
transshipments,
it really does enable
a scale of fishing
that was never possible before.
And so this is a
very sobering picture
in the hull of a boat
in the Galapagos.
And you're literally looking
at thousands and thousands
of sharks that have
been finned and cut.
And what ended up happening as
we zoom out, as you can see,
how they've been removed
in different areas.
These are hammerhead
sharks and silky sharks.
There are some tuna
in there as well.
And so working with National
Geographic, as well as many
of the Galapagos
conservative groups,
they were able to go in.
And they said that these
were thousands, if not
tens of thousands of sharks.
This is historic.
This is the biggest seizure
of sharks in the history
of Galapagos, for sure.
And what happened in the end
is the boat that they caught
was fined about $6 million, and
the crew is currently in jail.
And the Ecuadorian Navy
did an incredible job
of bringing that in
and then trying them
in their court systems.
But what they tried them for
is somewhat of a loophole,
because they were transporting
endangered species
through a marine protected area.
But what Global Fishing Watch
is allowing people to do
is start to understand that
network of other vessels
that were involved in
that and transshipped
their catch onto this boat,
because this boat itself wasn't
the one that was doing
all of that fishing.
DAVID KROODMSA: So I think
that's a really good point,
that the fishing was
actually happening elsewhere
in the ocean.
And really what's
exciting this is
that the high seas, the ocean,
is kind of this last frontier
and this area that's synonymous
with things that you can't tell
is happening there.
And so what happens
is that we over-fish,
and all those things are caught.
And all these dangerous
species are being caught.
And it's a huge
management problem.
And once you can see what's
actually happening there,
people can start to take
action and do something.
And so I think that--
it's a place where I
think it's really--
like new data is
really exciting,
because it makes a difference.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: This
is another example.
This is the Sanchi.
This was an oil tanker that
crashed with another vessel
out in the middle
of the Asia-Pacific.
And because it had so much oil
and other toxic [INAUDIBLE]
on it, it ignited, and it
burned for well over a week
in the middle of the high seas.
And so this was an
oil spill that's
on par with a lot of
the other famous ones
that people have
heard about in the US.
But because it's happening out
in the middle of the ocean,
it's not really getting
any coverage the same way.
And it's really,
really difficult
to estimate what the
impact this will have
as toxins are
leaking out all over.
And because we've made all
of our data completely open,
Reuters has gone
on, and they started
modeling what the effects of
that tanker are going to be.
And so they built
out an area that
looked at where the oil
was going to spread.
And then, they brought in all
the Global Fishing Watch data
as well and were able to
say over that same two
or three-week period
that they were able to--
actually, I think it was
about a three-month period
that they modeled out where
the oil was able to go,
they could see which
fishing grounds
were going to be affected.
And as we look at other ways
of integrating Global Fishing
Watch data, there's
a huge opportunity
to work with local markets
so that you could actually
see where your fish was caught
and whether it may or may not
have been in the
vicinity of some
of these natural disasters
or man-made disasters
as they're happening.
There's another example here
that's, I think, very telling.
Traditionally, when new
marine protected areas
wanted to be created,
there is often
pushback from local
industry and other areas.
And what's happening
here is there
is a new marine protected
area they were trying
to create in Mexico, and that's
this little red box in here
that they tried to do.
And I'll try to do this live.
We'll see if it
cooperates this time.
One more time.
And so when they went in,
the industry had said,
look, if you close
this area to fishing,
we'll lose job security.
We'll lose the fish that
we need to feed the country
and everything else.
And traditionally, this
has been very one-sided,
because industry has
had this information,
but governments and NGOs and
other public interest groups
have not had access to this.
With Global Fishing
Watch, they were
able to say, OK, here is
everywhere the Mexican fishing
vessels are fishing.
And what we're able to see is
that that little red area there
is less than 4%
of the total fish
and the total profits that
are being collected by this.
And a lot of the work is being
done out in the high seas.
DAVID KROODMSA: And
I just want to say
it's really great, because
these arguments usually--
they can start
having conversations
about actual numbers and
things once you bring this
to the table.
Because before, it's like people
come to the table with like,
no, marine protected areas
are going destroy our business
or marine protected
areas are great,
and they're going
to save the ocean.
And now, we can actually
say, we're actually to save--
they're going to prevent
this percentage of fishing
and save this much area.
And then, that allows you to
actually make progress and have
real conversations.
BRIAN SULLIVAN:
And in that case,
National Geographic
and Pristine Seas
has a program where they
work with local governments
to enable them to have access to
this other type of information
and figure out, from a
scientific perspective, where
these policies can be done.
And in the last
year or two, they
have actually created new five
marine protected areas using
data from Global Fishing Watch.
Some of these areas are
larger than California,
twice the size of Germany,
and we're seeing this
all over the world now.
And we're really
excited about it.
So one of the things
that's exciting about this
is that Global Fishing Watch
would not have been possible
five years ago.
Satellite data didn't have the
global coverage that we need.
From a regulatory perspective,
a lot of these vessels
did not used to
publicly broadcast,
and we're seeing more and
more pressure from that.
But then finally, the
computing power was never there
to handle massive, massive
amounts of this data
and be able to scale
it over an area
that you didn't have to be a
hardcore computer programmer
to start to be able to
tease out that information
and be able to visualize
everything in a simple web
page that's free and public
and anybody in the world
can go in and see that.
And so we're really
excited by the fact
that five years ago,
this wasn't possible.
It's just starting
to be possible now.
And it keeps
growing and growing.
And a lot of the things
that you've seen,
we've done all just off of the
equivalent of a GPS broadcast.
But now the next wave
is going to be looking
at all kinds of satellite
imagery and radar
and other ones to get an even
bigger sense of what extent
we're fishing our
oceans, so we can better
manage them for the future.
So thanks very
much, and I think we
have questions coming shortly.
All right, well welcome back.
All right, so we have some
questions from the audience.
Some of these are
often the questions
we frequently get
asked, and there's
a couple new ones in here too.
So all right, the first
question is, why can't boats
just turn off their AIS,
and you'll never see them?
DAVID KROODMSA: They can.
That's the answer.
But the trick is, you can
see when they turn it off,
if they're away from shore.
And so you can-- and
that's suspicious,
so we can highlight it.
And we've done
some analyses where
we compare the number of days
at sea for certain fleets
with official statistics,
and it does quite well.
So this is a problem in some
specific parts of the world
that we have to do
more investigation on.
But for most of the data set,
it is not a huge problem.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: OK.
And actually, I think Oceana,
another nonprofit that we've
worked with, recently
released a report where
they looked across the globe.
And they said, show
me examples of boats
that have kind of consistently
been turning off their AIS just
as they're approaching
protected areas
or other exclusive
economic zones.
And we're not saying
what's legal or illegal,
but we're putting
the data out there
to start having conversations.
And we think that's
really the value
of transparent information.
DAVID KROODMSA: And
to be clear, there
are places where
this is an issue that
requires that type of attention
that Oceana has brought to.
BRIAN SULLIVAN:
OK, so do you see
any difference between
running the machine learning
models and virtual machines
versus in Cloud ML?
And did you get any uplift?
And have you played
with GPUs or TPUs?
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah,
those are good questions.
Cloud ML is really nice
because of the auto-scaling.
So you don't need
to officially--
you don't have to allocate all
of your machines beforehand.
And it's allowed us to do
things much more efficiently.
We have not been able to use
TPUs, Tensor Processing Units,
but we have moved to GPUs,
which have about 10 to 20 times
more efficient--
faster than doing our model
on CPUs, which is really nice.
Makes a big difference.
BRIAN SULLIVAN:
And I think what's
happened is not only
is it so much faster,
but then it also
decreases your costs.
Because you're not running
the machines for as long as
you need.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: All right, so
it sounds like you're basing
this whole project off of AIS--
other types of tracking
information you can use?
So I think we actually touched
on that a little bit in there.
So governments like
Indonesia are coming forward
and providing their own
vessel monitoring system data.
And so I was actually--
in June of last year
at the UN Oceans event,
we stood up with Ibu Susi,
and we launched all the
Indonesian data in there
as well.
And since then, we've actually
built out a team of about three
or four people that are
in Indonesia working
with the local government
to provide them
access to these tools and build
the type of custom reports
and tools that they need
to push these further.
And we also talked a little
bit about how we're just
starting to use a lot more
satellite imagery and radar
and other areas to measure
what we call the dark fleet,
or vessels that
aren't broadcasting.
DAVID KROODMSA: And
we're actually soon going
to be adding to Global Fishing
Watch a layer where you can--
there's another
thing called VIIRS,
which is a satellite from NOAA,
that looks at night lights.
And so squid fishing vessels
fish with really bright lights,
and so these satellites
can actually see those.
And we're starting to match
those up to fishing vessels.
And we'll be able to see--
you'll be able see
that soon in Global
Fishing Watch, that
layer of that satellite.
And so you'll be able to
see those night lights.
And it is really
interesting, there's
some places where there's
boats that don't have AIS
but are fishing squid.
And you can see that
now in this map.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: How can
people get access to the data?
DAVID KROODMSA:
Globalfishingwatch.org
and globalfishingwatch.io.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: All
right, that works.
Just Google it.
DAVID KROODMSA: Just
Google it, yeah.
So the raw AIS tracks, we
can't release all of those,
because some of those
are proprietary.
But we have high-resolution
gridded fishing effort
by vessel and--
that you can-- by day.
So you can really
kind of dig down
to the results of these models.
BRIAN SULLIVAN:
And I think you've
made it available in CSVs,
in BigQuery directly,
so you can play with it.
It's also been rasterized and
available on Earth Engine.
So if you want to bring it
in along with sea surface
temperature, or depth
and others like that,
it's all in one package already.
DAVID KROODMSA: And on
globalfishingwatch.io, there's
sample code and blog posts
to describe each of those,
so BigQuery and Earth
Engine, how to access them.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: OK.
DAVID KROODMSA: I
highly recommend
using those over the CSVs.
Because the CSVs just give
you the 25-gigabyte file,
and it's much
harder to deal with.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: And then
finally, in the last 30
seconds, what's wrong?
Where are the holes?
Where do you lack coverage?
DAVID KROODMSA: Oh, nowhere.
It's perfect.
[CHUCKLING]
So the main issue is that
not all boats have AIS,
and it varies by region.
We dove into this on a
recent science publication.
You can look in the
supplementary materials.
There's a large table
segged by country.
But we have documented
this quite extensively.
There's also some regions
where AIS coverage is not
quite as good.
But by and large, it's a
problem that we can address.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: Great.
DAVID KROODMSA: Great.
BRIAN SULLIVAN: All right,
well thanks so much.
It was a pleasure today.
And I think there's
another one coming next.
DAVID KROODMSA: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]